Speaker 1: There is another audio recording
of House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy, who's
a Republican, making it very clear that he
wants Trump out.
This is truly incredible stuff.
And it actually it's not improving my opinion
of McCarthy.
It's actually worsening it.
And I'll explain why.
New audio report CNN.
McCarthy said 25th Amendment takes too long.
In other words, the 25th Amendment would take
too long to remove Trump he wanted as a Republican
who publicly supported Trump privately, McCarthy
wanted Trump removed, wanted to reach out
to Biden after the January 6th attack.
This is incredible.
House Republican leader Kevin McCarthy discussed
the 25th Amendment is a mechanism to remove
a sitting president on a call with Republican
leadership days after the January six, 2021
attack on the Capitol and said the process
takes too long.
According to audio obtained by the New York
Times and shared with CNN, he also said he
wanted to reach out to then President elect
Biden to hope for a smooth transition and
said he thought an impeachment would further
divide the nation.
Let's listen to that audio revealed yesterday
to CNN by The New York Times reporters.
This is incredible stuff.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
It was atrocious and totally wrong.
I was down.
We were 12 days away at one point, only good
bye.
If you have an impeachment and you're stuck
sitting in the Senate and he needs Cabinet
members, you've got senators and you've got
a lot of fans, you've got to have them.
And from their perspective, you've put everything
else away.
This country's very, very divided.
I do say to the impeachment divide, the further
it continues, the fight is great.
That's why I want to reach across the aisle.
I want as a president to lead the fight if
that's going to happen.
I want to see about as leading advisors sit
him down, make the transition a show that
is to you to keep those statements going to
help you.
I need to talk to Pelosi this week.
I hope she calls me today and see if we can
start that process.
Speaker 1: This is incredible stuff.
I truly hope that's the end of the clip.
This makes these people look way worse.
So every time we learn something like this,
there's kind of two perspectives right there
as well.
One perspective is these people aren't as
crazy as we thought in the sense that they
realized how dangerous Trump was and they
actually did want him gone.
That's one perspective.
They're not as bad.
The other perspective is these people are
even worse because it's not that they genuinely
believed Trump won and the riots were good
and all this different stuff.
They knew the opposite was true, but they
continued publicly saying the things that
they had to say in order to stay in Trump's
good graces or whatever the case may be.
I believe that the latter is accurate.
These people are worse because Kevin McCarthy
knew better.
He knew better.
He was saying it.
He was on the phone with Liz Cheney.
He was on the phone with whoever.
And he continued to pander and to risk American
democracy because of whatever selfish or self-centered
reasons made him do it publicly.
He says, Oh, it was atrocious and it was totally
wrong.
What Trump did, we got to look at the 25th
Amendment, and yet publicly he just continued
to do his thing and say, Now everything's
good.
Republicans are good, everything's good.
So is it a desire for power and money and
continuing to have access to the president
that influence that?
Is there some connection?
And we're speculating here between whatever
made Ted Cruz and Lindsey Graham 180 on Trump.
Remember, those were not people who ever supported
Trump early and then all of a sudden they
love Trump.
They think he's great.
Is there some connection between that and
whatever kept McCarthy publicly supporting
Trump?
Could it be as simple as polling, they say?
Listen, most of the base supports this guy,
so we've got to support this guy.
All of this confirms McCarthy is saying enough
to know about the toxicity and the atrocity
of Trump, and yet he still actively chose
to allow it.
And that makes him, I believe, worse than
if he was a true believer in this kind of
gets back to the conversation we've been having
for a week or two now about what's worse,
the true believers or the false believers.
The 25th Amendment was exactly for situations
like these where the president has become
so compromised, he can't think straight, he
can't discharge his duty as president of the
United States.
He's lost his mind and some of the people
closest to him, I guess they knew it had been
enough, but they chose not to act.
And they continue, Republicans do, to tell
Democrats now that they've got to clean up
the mess, that it's actually Republicans and
Trump is to create it.
Now, one other question.
We've been playing these recordings of Kevin
McCarthy for weeks now.
Has Fox even talked about them?
Do Fox News viewers even know that these recordings
exist?
I genuinely don't know the answer.
I mean, it's not like I sit around and watch
Fox.
Do they have any idea of what we've learned
from these recordings over the last few weeks?
I don't know the answer to that.
But if the answer is no.
This goes to our story about two Americas
that exist.
And it's very, very disturbing stuff.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at D Pacman.
We are an audience supported program.
And on that note, I'd love for you to support
the work that we do.
The Daily Podcast, YouTube clips, TV show,
radio show, live streams, premium newsletter,
all of the different things.
The easiest way is to sign up at join Packman
dot com.
It's quick, it's easy.
There's no big company taking ten, 20, 30%
slices of every dollar.
We keep everything but a 2.9% payment processing
fee and you can get a discount using the coupon
code.
Speaker 2: Obama Oh, bomb now major discount.
Speaker 1: In fact, I won't even tell you
how big of a discount it is.
It's a little.
It makes me blush how big of a discount it
as you can sign up it join Pacman dot com